what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we are finally getting into Dark
Knight's medal number four this has
finally come out the way that DC is
doing this isn't the way that you
normally see comic books done which is
to say when it comes to massive
crossover events usually you have like
the main story which is published either
bi-weekly or published monthly and then
you have tie-ins which usually just kind
of come out but the problem with this is
that with everything going on in DC
rebirth if do you see were to follow the
common trend which is you know the Dark
Knight's metal comic every two weeks and
then you have all the tions plus all the
stories that are going on it would
actually be pretty overwhelming so while
we basically ran into Dark Knights metal
1 2 & 3 being published you know weekly
bi-weekly what-have-you and then in turn
picking up with issue number 4 which
kind of goes into this process of
releasing it monthly more or less we did
have all these extra tires the origin
stories different things like that which
helped to sort of compensate and fill in
the gaps now one of the big questions
that I see a lot from people is when
does Dark Knight's metal take place now
a comic story and in a video about this
so I'll have that video link to the
description you guys can go check it out
but the long and short of it is that is
for the most part believed Dark Knight's
metal takes place before Doomsday Clock
you don't really know until we get into
Doomsday Clock full-bore which is to say
we're three four five issues into it we
basically have a good understanding of
where the continuity is so the cool
thing about Dark Knight's metal number
four is that it takes this traditional
role of Scott Snyder storytelling and
what I mean by that is those of you guys
who read as new 52 run who saw the
videos that we did court of owls nine of
owls in game death of the family those
of you guys who you know saw those
videos that read those stories you're
very familiar with the way the Scott
Snyder does his storytelling for those
of you guys who are not familiar what he
usually does is he does like you know
say here's how many issues it is you
know and then once you get to about the
halfway mark that's what it basically
turns them to like Empire Strikes Back
all the information starts flowing out
everything that's happened so far gets
consolidated into a really nice neat
package the first half of the story is
peeking your interest the middle is
explaining everything the third is the
conclusion and even his whole runs go
that way but when you take like Dark
Knight's medal and you roll it all
together you basically start with Batman
number one when it came to the new 52
and he went all the way up to Dark
Knight's Medal this filled in all the
gaps of the quarter valves why did the
court of owls care about Batman so much
and all those different things and so
that's we're gonna do in this video for
those of you guys who find yourselves
feeling a little confused or a little
left out with regards to understanding
everything that's going on
this should be able to explain it better
than pretty much everything we've done
so far because it's designed to serve
that purpose and so initially what we do
here is you basically pick up with the
location of Superman and Batman really
more so Batman than anything else now
the funny thing about this is remember
when it comes to the passage of time
within the DC landscape while DC does
not directly hit on it it's kind of this
unwritten rule that time may or may not
pass differently relative to what's
going on in the universe as a whole
which is to say just because it takes
365 days for a quote-unquote year to
pass which is really just the earth
going around Sun it doesn't mean time
passes the same way people might age
faster in a different universe
they might age slower in a different
universe when it comes to the dark
multiverse we don't fully understand it
what we do know is that with Batman
having been stranded in the dark
multiverse and being held by Barbados as
forces for what may amount to seven or
eight days within the Dark multiverse
itself time has passed in decades and so
essentially Batman's age like thirty
years since he's been in the dark
multiverse now it kind of makes logical
sense but something else that I also
want you guys to notice here is that
where he is being held captive by these
various forces these dark multiverse
versions of Superman one of the versions
you notice here is the man of energy and
this is really really cool so a little
bit of history here for those guys who
don't know the man of energy is the guy
who's who's in the blue and the white
back during the the 1990s when DC killed
off Superman when they brought him back
it was like this massive backlash people
bought the Death of Superman believing
it was going to be this massive iconic
thing and it wasn't a lot of ways and so
with him basically dying people were
just like oh my god this is insane and
the DC brought him back within a year
and so people felt betrayed so much like
max landis pointed out in his video on
the death and return of Superman it
basically tanked the sales of his comics
for years in an effort to basically
reinvigorate popularity in Superman DC
came along with the idea of splitting
him in half and they took the original
red kryptonite story where you basically
had blue and red red Clark in basically
a good Clark Kent and bad Clark Kent
good Superman bad Superman and they turn
them into like the man of energy now I
don't really remember the specifics
surrounding it I do know a lot of people
hated it they did not like it at all but
nonetheless it is it was kind of an
interesting thing now one of the big
questions people have is how does the
Dark multiverse work how do these
characters work in relation to like the
positive multiverse that gets explained
here so all of this will make sense here
in
but one of the other things that goes on
is the question people ask why Superman
and Batman is it really just because
they're like the top two characters in
DC to degree that's true but it's also
because of the roles they play remember
you know with regards to the events of
Final Crisis the idea that Batman was
thrown back in time you know and then
Barbados noticed him for the first time
and basically said I can find a way to
enter the positive multiverse and stay
there
the ultimate goal was to not only open a
doorway but to keep that doorway open so
what's the equivalent of keeping the
door open what's the brick at the base
of the door that's Superman that's the
role he plays he's kind of like this
cosmic battery so to speak because of
the fact that he's supercharged the
solar energy because he's so powerful
what this means is that when he was
captured by the forces of Barbados he
was a source of energy that was used to
keep the doorway open now remember the
basis behind this is because of the fact
that it all comes down to invasion
Barbados leading his forces into the
positive multiverse with the intention
of invading it via introduction of these
dark multiverse versions of Superman all
that was designed to do is say it's not
just evil verses of Batman
there's evil versions of Batman
presumably there's evil versions of
Wonder Woman there's evil versions of
the Green Lantern now again we'll find
out why that is but the funny thing
about this is that with Batman having
been held for like the last 30 years or
so within the dark multiverse at least
you know perceiving himself to been held
for thirty years the whole base is the
whole motivation behind this is he seen
virtually every possible scenario where
he screws up that's the torture that
he's put through is to see every
scenario where everything that can go
wrong has gone wrong as a result of
course he's really kind of been been
able to develop not necessarily this
sort of antibody quote-unquote to the
whole you know experiment but in the
sense that his mind has gotten to a
point where he's begun to be able to
overcome it and because of the fact that
Superman is the source of energy used to
keep the portal open the main motivation
of Bruce is to grab Superman and get out
of there now the cool thing about this
is that what we end up doing is actually
transitioning away from Batman as
Superman and we pick up in the rock of
eternity now the rock of eternity has
been a pretty huge discussion piece for
the Dark multiverse and the reason for
this is because in the last video in the
last story we had talked about how with
the earth in a lot of ways having been
conquered by the forces of Barbados
those last remaining heroes and even
some villains like like like Deathstroke
had basically banded together in saying
we have to put our problems aside and we
have to focus on saving the world as
we can't and so what they ended up doing
these last vestiges of people began
spreading around to all these different
locations traveling to all these places
in an effort to try to find in metal
which is the only material known to be
able to successfully defeat Barbados so
what ended up happening here is with the
characters of Wonder Woman and with
Saunders and with dr. fate they travel
to the rock of eternity simply because
they had picked up that there was in
that'll within the rock of eternity
itself the characters of Deathstroke and
Aquaman went to Atlantis because they
found in the metal there too when it
came to a mr. terrific alongside the
Green Lantern they traveled to the
planet of Fanta gar which is where
Hawkman was from and then finally you
had the flash and you have cyborg who
traveled into the multiverse to try to
find help and so again that's probably
the more interesting part of the story
is what that means with regards to those
characters traveling out there but
picking up with Wonder Woman the reason
why the rock of eternity was so
intriguing is because one of the big
questions people have is where is Shazam
we know Shazam operates out of the rock
of eternity and so if they were going to
travel to the rock of eternity then that
would be the most likely case where we
would see him but when they arrive here
they're basically met with the
representation of the seven deadly sins
now remember in DC Comics the seven
deadly sins are basically kind of
captured and contained by the wizard
Shazam the being that gave Billy Batson
his powers now of course these guys
function more or less as guardians
because Robert the rock of eternity does
house a lot of powerful artifacts but
the rock of eternity is also a gateway I
think of it like a hallway of doors if
you go into the rock of eternity you can
access almost any universe within the
multiverse and so because of that to
them arriving here is basically the
activation of a security system and so
of course with these representations of
the seven sins showing up and basically
you know trying to defend the city
against them it is kind of intriguing
because you're talking about beings of
immense power but the whole idea behind
this is you know what these sends more
or less defeated then the question
becomes where is this info now of course
it's believed the implemental stems from
the mace of Hawkman and of course again
we'll explain all that stuff once we get
to the whole origin of Barbados but the
problem with this is that as they go
through dr. fate begins to sort of take
up on what's believed to be this kind of
evil that's lurking down in the shadows
now we can interpret that in one of two
ways
either we can interpret that as that's
just kind of the aura that infidel puts
off or we can interpret that as Yuga con
and that's kind of the funny thing about
this remember when it comes to Yuga Khan
he's the father of Darkseid and the
whole
Pantheon but the whole basis behind this
is if you VidCon launched a campaign he
entered into the DC Multiverse
so to speak that ultimately he would
basically lay waste to everyone that's
why it was when we covered Hal Jordan in
the Green Lantern Corps with the fall of
the gods storyline that when it came to
Yuga Khan he was still locked within the
source wall had his force has been
successful and released him almost all
hope would have been lost now what we
end up doing from here is transitioning
over to Deathstroke and Aquaman now
again this is kind of a funny moment
here because Deathstroke is very much a
devil-may-care character and what I mean
by that is he puts off the air of I
don't really care what goes on don't
really care about what you do I care
about what I want to do but in reality
and one of the things you're seeing now
when it comes to Deathstroke defiance
his own solo Series in DC rebirth is a
Deathstroke it's actually a pretty deep
guy but the whole team up between
Aquaman and Deathstroke is in a lot of
ways a pretty interesting scenario
because where Aquaman is more or less
you know like we're here in Atlantis
we're trying to find this in metal guest
jokes like don't have time for that
don't much care but with them searching
for info metal because they basically
hone in on this sacred tomb in Atlantis
Deathstroke it's kind of plunges a sword
in there and it's like look we don't
have time for ceremony the world's
coming to an end we got to figure out
what's going on only for them to find
out did the casket is basically a portal
of sorts that leads down into a whole
other location which they end up diving
into never here we pick up with one of
the more interesting concepts when it
comes to DC and we jump into thin egg
our prime now of course stanag arc is
the home planet of like Hawkman and you
know Hawk woman and so on and so forth
but the cool thing about this is that
with the arrival of Hal Jordan what we
end up finding out is that thanagar has
basically been taken over by ona Mars
sin who well he's actually somewhat of
an interesting character when it came to
the character of autumn our sin he
appeared back in JSA number 23 in 2001
and he was created by David Goyer now
JSA back then was kind of like the
counterpart to the Justice League I
guess the JLA story it was started by
Grant Morrison at the time if the JSA
title was being written by like David
Goyer and Geoff Johns and so on and so
forth
Oh Tamar's sin basically being brought
in was designed to hit home at this
notion that when it came to the planet
of Fanta gar that it had very much a
tumultuous history and Audemar sin was
one of the people who had basically
risen to prominence and tried on a
multitude of occasions to conquer the
planet on his own now this basically ran
into events like the the RAM
a Naggar war which took place you know
it's part of the whole what does it
infinite crisis I think it was countdown
to Infinite Crisis storyline there are a
lot of things that went into that in
terms of you know the whole history of
the planet so on and so forth trying to
kind of reshuffle the origin of Hawkman
and Hawk woman things like that for the
umpteenth time however many times DC's
tried it but as far as I'm aware we're
not really given this sort of gap that
bridges things was just to say we don't
really know how onnum our sin came back
what we know is that he was defeated and
just kind of scattered among the
spaceways and that was really about it
but somewhere along the line he made his
return now originally he was a guy who
was imprisoned in an emetic prison of
course what ended up doing was basically
channeling those properties into himself
consuming as much info mental as he
could to imbue him so with all these
energies which is what you basically see
here where he's got these you know metal
armbands more or less for lack of a
better word that's composed of earth
metal the whole idea of putting it on
himself was to attract these heroes here
and the reason why he looked to attract
these heroes here was because while
Barbados is you know tearing everything
up on earth the contingency plan of
thanagar
was to essentially create this cannon
that would obliterate the entirety of
earth should it ever begin to run awry
now one of the things this also hits
home at is the notion that when it comes
to what goes on on earth a lot of other
planets that exist out there don't
necessarily trust humanity and this was
kind of interesting about this but what
we also end up finding out is that all
of our sin has allied himself with star
oh and this is cool because this is a
throwback to Justice League number one
back in 1960 now of course this also
leads to you know these various members
here being more less taken prisoner by
one of our sin for the purpose of being
used for his own ends but it is
intriguing because what we end up doing
here is we jump back to the whole idea
of Batman and Superman now of course
with them having kind of left the Dark
multiverse they look aged just like we
would expect them to but they also end
up meeting with dream of the endless now
again we talked about how true of the
endless was one of these various beings
out there who sort of embodied these
concepts where he was the concept of
dream but what he ends up doing is he
ends up grabbing Superman and Batman and
basically taking them to a place called
the Lucian library and this is
interesting because what he basically
tells them is that this is a place where
everyone dreams this is all their
catalogue dreams of the whole nine yards
when you sleep at night and you dream
your mind comes here you kind of walk
this ethereal plane more or less but
with dreams also come nightmares and
that's the cool thing about this is
because dream basically says I cannot
directly help you I can't really step
and act on your behalf and fight
alongside you guys what I can do is give
you something more important I can
basically give you information now
something that I hope you guys notice
here are the words of Scott Snyder uses
because what he's basically doing here
is he's building up the whole DC cosmic
landscape and that's what's cool because
unlike Marvel Comics DC's cosmic
landscape is not really fleshed out and
Marvel is fleshed out pretty well just
because of the fact that you had stories
from guys like Steve Englehart jim
Starlin who built a lot of the cosmic
landscape a Marvel decided to blackball
and recently you had a lot of cosmic
building that's been going on for
decades and decades in DC Comics you
don't really have that but the whole
cool thing about this is that this is
really kind of Snyder basically giving
us the crisis on Infinite Earths origin
of the universe without explicitly
telling us the origin of the universe
according to crisis on Infinite Earths
has been told so many times we don't
need to see the exact same thing of the
hand rising out of the you know
beginning of creation and all that kind
of good stuff instead you know it's kind
of like this brief run over were
basically told in the beginning there
was just darkness and that from this
darkness came life and with this life
came the positive multiverse and the
antimatter universe and so what you had
is in the positive multiverse you had
the monitor who was basically designed
to kind of you know overlook everything
and make sure everything was doing what
it's supposed to but of course we also
have the anti-monitor who we know is you
know kinda like the harbinger of
destruction that death of the multiverse
but what Scott Snyder does here is he
brings in kind of like this third being
who just created universes what this
does is it kind of answers the question
where life came from these universes
that were created we're basically done
by some being who existed down in the
world Forge and what this person would
do is it would craft universes and send
them out they're the most stable of the
universes were basically allowed to go
into the multiverse the positive matter
multiverse the unstable universes were
confined back to the dark multiverse who
is basically a holding ground for those
universes that don't work the problem
with this is that this world Forge more
or less essentially had this kind of
dragon of sorts and this dragon will
basically consume the various worlds
that were considered to be unstable
somewhere along the line this dragon was
corrupted this dragon basically became a
villain and then killed a forger of
worlds that dragon is Barbados following
that the dragon in turn basically went
on this campaign to expand its own power
the cool thing about this is that this
hits home directly to everything that's
happened so far and that's why I say
this will all essentially come together
the way
hardline seems to play out is that where
this dragon basically Barbados killed
the forger of worlds instead of these
worlds just give him quality control
more or less the dragon kind of fell
asleep at the wheel in the sense that
all these worlds started going out there
instead of them being consumed and
destroyed they just started filling up
the Dark multiverse and that's why you
have so many of these worlds out there
but somewhere along the line what ended
up happening here is that Carter Hall
basically when he was the original
Hawkman he would countered in metal and
when he did his main enemy was a guy
named hath-set when it came to the
character of hath-set he was looked upon
bar Barbados and Barbados saw him as a
means to basically enter the positive
multiverse when Barbados made his move
and used hath-set to enter the positive
multiverse he encountered Hawkman this
in turn led to a battle between the two
now of course the infidel mace was used
to defeat Barbados and that's where the
standard comes from that entha metal is
the only material known that can defeat
Barbados and anybody else from the Dark
multiverse this in turn sent Barbados
retreating because Barbados retreated
and because of the fact that the bat
tribe was formed the formation of the
bat tribe led to the formation of the
owl tribe which is where the court of
owls come from the court of owls are
kind of a more extreme group of the bat
tribe who believed legitimately in
Barbados and follow Barbados as ideology
that Batman has to be the means by which
Barbados can make his return and that's
why ever since the court of owls came
into existence their main goal has to
always been prepare things for the
arrival of Barbados by waiting it to the
time when Bruce Wayne becomes Batman and
then imbuing him with all these metals
turning him into a doorway all these
things led to the arrival of Barbados
and so because of this this is where it
all kind of comes to a head and so where
we ended up having this idea that dream
essentially says I can open a portal and
get you to where you need to go in order
to find this world fort in order to
ensure that this is the only place that
you can go to basically find the
materials necessary to beat Barbados the
other questions asked well what if he's
conquered the world forge already what
if the world forge has been used and
turned into a dark tool if that's the
case then all hope is effectively lost
and so again it's kind of like this race
against time and so what we end up doing
is we end up jumping back to Wonder
Woman back in this rock of eternity in
the centre of the multiverse and what we
end up finding out here is that Saunders
has basically brought the brain of the
anti-monitor under the
leave that if it's thrown into this rift
more or less so than the multiverse
itself that it'll destroy the dark
multiverse so it'll kind of create this
feedback loop that'll lead to the
destruction of the dark multiverse when
in reality what she doesn't know is that
if she throws it in there it'll
obliterate the entirety of the
multiverse because what it'll do is
it'll see the return of the anti-monitor
now the return of the anti-monitor of
course as we know is basically the
harbinger the the representation of the
end of all things if he's given a
physical form he'll obliterate all
things that existence he'll just start
hopping through and destroying universes
everywhere he finds him but the whole
goal is to keep that from happening and
so what is it taking place is that where
she's initially subdued by Wonder Woman
the brain basically bonds itself to her
and in turn turns Saunders into lady
black hawk basically turning her into
this kind of evil being now where dr.
fate goes to intervene what is up
happening is dr. fate is blasted with a
shock of lightning and where we end up
finding out is that lightning comes from
Black Adam which is huge because this is
I was hoping you'd be Shazam like Adam
is the main enemy of Shazam himself not
only that what we end up finding out
here is that where Barbados his forces
had arrived on earth and started
conquering all these different
territories where it was largely
believed that either villas were at
hiding or villains had been taken out or
something along those lines that not
everyone did instead Vandal Savage and
Black Adam had basically come together
and struck a bargain with Barbados what
that bargain is we don't know but that
makes sense I mean you're talking about
Vandal Savage because one of the oldest
beings in existence he was there when
Batman was first thrown back in time and
we kind of have to presume that he's
well aware of who Barbados is just
because of the fact that he's one of the
immortal man who was brought together by
Carter Hall and Carter Hall explained
everything that was going on back when
that group was first formed but block
Adam is a protector of his country first
and man worries about everything else
later as though if Barbados shows up on
earth and says I'm going to conquer
everything here it makes sense it like
Adam would strike a bargain to keep his
people preserved the other half of this
is that Wonder Woman is no match for a
black atom if it's a legitimate fight
between the two because we're black adam
has all these godly powers at his
disposal
Wonder Woman could be shot with a bullet
and killed and so it's kind of
intriguing and it's kind of cool because
what is up happening is that as this
wraps up we end up transitioning to the
forge of worlds to this place that
Batman and Superman are arriving to
under the hope that they could basically
save everything only to arrive there in
fun the forge of worlds was one of the
first things that Barbados had basically
conquered and what this seems to
indicate is that there is no hope
there's no conceivable way to
successfully defeat Barbados
there's no way to forge anymore in metal
there's virtually no implemental left in
the positive multiverse there's
basically no conceivable way to win here
not only that what we end up finding out
is that the person who's basically
designed to stand guard for this forge
of worlds its Carter Hall himself
Hawkman who's been transformed into this
wildly powerful being now again how
powerful he is we won't know until you
know we get further along into the story
but it's cool because everything is
hitting home to this point there's no
conceivable way to stop Barbados how do
they win how do things go back to normal
how in the world can the day be saved
when there doesn't seem to be a way to
save the day at all but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come
this explained make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
pork the guys enjoy this video make sure
you drop a like and that will catch you
all later peace
[Music]